maintenant bon alors c'est le retour de
kelly vdo vénitien kelly mais novaes ni
vous le savez je dit aux téléspectateurs
à l'idée qu'elle iv novelli était au
portugal au portugal avec un homme mène
elle croit qu'on est le cap horn et libé
novelli j'aurai trois questions à vous
poser nagra répondait sans détour et
avec la franchise qui vous caractérisent
premièrement la question que tout le
monde se pose est ce que vous avez bien
manger au portugal alors écoutez j'ai
découvert le poisson au portugal ah oui
alors j'ai tellement attendu d'allopass
[Applaudissements]
qualité dopés ni avant d'aller au
portugal elle croyait que les poissons
ont été pêchés directement au carré
voilà croit les logan break avec man
captain igloo il existait vraiment hip
hop et des garrigues même été comme ça
non mais c'est vrai que ça n'a jamais
mangé des prêts poisson et du coup j'ai
mangé des sardines quoi vous avez pu
manger le poisson avec la tête et du
poisson non quand même pas avec la norme
et vous voyez les avait vu l'attaqué
sans soir ses débuts je les ai vus ils
ne sont pas tous à regarder l'accueil
les yeux alors vous avez vu quelques
c'était délicieux quel poisson non mais
faut savoir qu'à démissionner ces
incendies d'amoureux vous avez voté pour
moussavi la morue en nacre à l'amoureux
de la croatie connaissait sans accroc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
deuxième question a élévé de vba
vous êtes parti donc avec un garçon oui
ma question aller simple et clair et je
veux pas d'explication y en aura parce
que vous avez loué une chambre ou deux
choses importantes aussi élevé de alors
déjà on a la réponse à celle fait ça
faire c'est que c'est une chose est sûre
c'est une chambre en toute amitié
vous étiez dans la même chose qu'un mec
pendant convenu un mec c'est mon
meilleur ennemi à combien de jours à 4
jours c'est combien de nuits dont 3 4 4
jours et 4 nuits d'été que les dons et
lui le gars il était à portée de main
et le
[Applaudissements]
la famille qui s'en excuse moi ça va
aller je vais maintenant les jeunes ou
trop libre où le gars mais que tu alors
je le connais et j'aime beaucoup mais là
vous étiez comment gouverne nous avions
deux salles de bains chacun une salle de
bains chacun donc j'étais dans la mienne
j'avais fermé la boîte dans une chaude
et je lui ai dit je vais faire ma photo
ils tuent et moi vdev dit s'il vous
plaît les gens vous regardent les
français ont besoin de savoir le jsl
améliorer si on n'est pas là ici pour
mentir vitrine une salle de bains et une
chambre ouais alors franchement sur
youtube et démodé vous ridiculiser mais
ce qu'elle est un libre d'un canapé et
de télé un quine file - queen de télé
alors est-ce que ça dérange et un grand
lit donc vous étiez dans le même lit la
foule
oui c'était pas données séparées c'était
un grand ligue 1 elie et vas-y
condensats chez tous les êtres dans la
nuit justement on a fait un bail que
vous avez dans ma tête bêche on a fait
un base de paulhan son entrée à bâle
alors on n'était pas polochon sachets
d'eau
attention dénommé attention mais nos
vanités ou b novelli vous allez quoi je
veux faire tuer par chivu et par qui
vous avions fait reculer s'il vous plait
enlevez votre nom c'est pas votre petit
copain du portugal 3 1
c'est mon meilleur ami s'appelle axel et
je t'aime d'ailleurs excellent tabac
voilà pourquoi alors attendez à mener ma
troisième question est simple pourquoi
vous venez de dire je vais me faire tuer
oui par qui louche mais allez-y dwd
écouté beaucoup de soleil qui vous donne
chaussez vos morceaux le connais tu te
sentiras dans la fois que j'ai menti
c'est à mes parents quand j'avais dit
que j'avais eu 14 en histoire et en fait
j'avais eu 15 20 h 15 et 9 heures alors
oui alors oui alors oui que voulez vous
je vous ai posé une question les 9 et 10
j'ai oublié pourquoi vous avez dit je
vais me faire tuer going to be kind
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà pour demain les lions n'aura
la plus grande star mondiale
big star chypre à l'aide alors loi
espagnole et avec aïcha en france alors
au oui alors chef et la vienne me
demander si elle essaie de son gym de
changer de sujet maison félix et moi
verrait donc vous n'aurez pas répondait
séduction mais je le dis aux
téléspectateurs il est 19h30 on est en
direct un jeu peut annuler tous les
invités je peux approuver l'émission je
peux annuler également le site alors
derrière en peluche et à la télé des
monarques wind and on adore ouais alors
attention et kyle stan inédits en plus
comme il est dit que la chaîne va casser
les bonbons hier au lycée bien il est
alors pourquoi vous avez dit je vais me
faire tuer les novelli j'ai fait novelli
écoutez moi bien fait vous avez qu'est
ce que c'est que ça at il était pas une
et j'espère qu'il n'était pas sous la
piste
[Applaudissements]
et donc lui toute la journée la baffe
elecam a élégamment je vais me coucher
moi je vais en effet les photos aussi
d'accord je l'adoré en plein vol adore
alors oui ben alors dites moi pourquoi
ici pas ou s'en fout aller vite parce
que
parce qu'il est discret non non mais
veytaux vd
vous savez ce que vous allez faire ce
que moi je raconte ma vie y'a pas de
soucis mais j'ai pas envie de raconter
la vie des origines l'ong save espoirs 1
vous allez sortir
non ils vont viendrait quand vous serez
calmer quand vous êtes en mesure de dire
la vérité
d'accord oui c'est vrai d'accord vous
faites comme à l'école et vous tapez
pendant 35 ans vous tapez vous ouvrez la
porte là on va vous mettre une porte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les gars vous êtes une page ou taper et
quand vous serez calmez vous viendrez
parce que là les mensonges
j'en ai jusque là mais novelli d'accord
ils vont aussi être agité 1 qu'est ce
que c'est vous qui êtes un gîte à ces
salles plus la salle alors tu veux dire
il ya pas mal de choses qui ont changé
ici en avant et nous allons apprendre à
aller nouvelles règles car veut alors
allez faire un tour
non alors vous voulez peut-être dire la
vérité avoue partir non à non car elle
ne voulait pas dire la vérité
graff chef non là là là là on est en
train de toucher le fond de la piscine
afin d'entrevoir mal ça va trop loin
on peut partir elle a dit je peux partir
de là alors est ce qu il a dit laissez
la tranquille même
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ta les sortir tous les deux
vous allez faire un conciliabule savez
ce que ça veut dire c'est bon merci un
conciliabule discuter tous les deux
parce que je sais que tous les dossiers
pas non plus voilà j'ai discuté
vous allez revenir le temps de trouver
mais c'est vous qui allez parler et vous
allez vous dire toute la vérité mais on
verra où la ola rien du tout mais
nouvelles chaînes allez-y tous les
dryats qui a les a donnés
c'est au fait merci les prix nobel
vous allez vous parler c'est bon et
ouais mais pour les gens mais je la dois
les deux là alors il ya eu un truc
ouais je pense qu'il ya eu un truc moi à
moi alors oui mais au moins j'ai
maintenant j'ai dit je l'aï belge et
j'ai fait des trucs comme ça
bon d'accord elle est plus de la science
merci les excuses moi vous êtes vous
venez pour l'émission